he's a bit have you obviously you've
seen him in person yeah we train a lot
it's all dude oh you've trained with
them yeah he's a good dude he's a good
[__] dude and how's it Go training
oh [__] a man he he like everybody to
him is a [__] there's a video of me
like asking him to go light on people
and everybody to him dude is a [__]
punching bag you could be like shamaya
this guy is like three fights dude he's
new he's like he's a [__] 55 or don't
hurt him and she might have like I
understand I understand and actually you
know it's your eyes on top and beating
the [__] out of it training with that
intensity I respect that like if I go to
someone if I go to someone's gym and
unless a coach says hey be nice to this
[__] like I'm not gonna be nice
to your team I'm gonna try to knock them
all out